pensières le mal de vivre des harkis
reportage près de nice de bernard persia
le quartier de la condamine à drap dans
les alpes-maritimes
vingt mille habitants dans 200 familles
a requis une communauté qui hier soir à
exprimer un ras-le-bol mais sans aucun
acte de violence physique comme à
narbonne kobo hui ya deux jours les
problèmes sont les mêmes les fils de
harkis sont français et entendent
réclamer leur droit ici à la condamine
95 % d'entre eux sont au chômage
la plupart mal logés en fait ils
réclament une véritable insertion
regrettant par exemple de ne pouvoir
accéder à aucune responsabilité
associative dans un quartier dépourvu de
toute installation sportive ou de loisir
une espèce de ghettos sein duquel chaque
ars qui toutes générations confondues se
sont exclus laissé pour compte
vous voulez intégrer comme tout le monde
nous sommes en france et de bk nous nous
sommes croisés et je dis que ce qui
s'est passé hier c'est surtout et en
exprimant une solidarité avec les jeunes
de narbonne et pas spécialement que
narbonne toutes les communautés harkis
nous on est rejeté des deux côtés nous
sommes en jeu ne sont pas considérés
comme des arabes dont ils ne sont pas
considérés comme des français
une révolte qui a décidé ici de
s'organiser en créant un véritable
comité regroupant toutes les
associations de français musulmans des
environs afin de monter à paris pour y
rencontrer selon leurs voeux madame le
premier ministre en d'autres termes la
ou les solutions passeront
inévitablement par le dialogue entre les
harkis les communes les départements et
l'état ce n'est du reste qu'à ce seul
prix que chaque communauté chaque
religion chaque race trouvera son
équilibre